the series is set in Russia in the year
2140 where women have taken over the
planet and turned it into an
ultra-modern Society they no longer live
in crowded cities but in the countryside
where every family owns a villa in fact
the technology is so modern that an AI
housekeeper takes care of everything
they measure their owner's temperature
cook food for them play shows according
to their mood and even design new
clothes for them since men are no longer
the dominant species things like hate
violence and Wars have been eradicated
and the average life expectancy of women
has gone up to 150. I didn't realize men
were killing women when they turned 100
before the protagonist of the movie is
Lisa a 50 year old woman who works as a
history teacher at a local school one
morning as she watches the news a woman
is seen protesting about a burning issue
she wants all women to have the right to
reproduce naturally with men and not by
artificial insemination Lisa simply
scoffs at the news and gets ready for
her day after a while she heads to work
and we are given a brief overview of the
society which is heavily client on
technology kindness and discipline food
stalls are present near the roads from
which women can enjoy free meals video
calling can be done with the click of a
finger and there are fines for menial
offenses like putting the garbage in the
wrong trash can the penalty for such
offenses is the deduction of social
points which is also considered as
currency in this world moreover if
someone is obedient and does their job
well they are given free social points
shortly after Lisa arrives at her
workplace which is a futuristic shuttle
housing a few students wasting no time
she starts the class with a video
presentation which talks about the
history of mankind it reveals that since
the Inception of humanity men have
dominated Society but all it brought was
hate and violence decades passed by but
nothing changed in fact the world was
plunging into deeper problems like
global warming the ozone layer depletion
and so on all definitely the fault of
men then in the year 2030 a deadly
conflict between the United States and
North Korea changed everything some
scientists in Pyongyang developed a
virus to destroy all the men in the U.S
military however the virus quickly
spread to other parts of the world too
and decimated 99 of the male population
did Donald Trump write this movie as the
video continues it shows that after the
women took over they slowly started
reversing the damages done by men global
warming began to lessen pollution levels
decreased animals started multiplying in
number and overall the earth started
becoming a better place to live at last
the video mentions that the birth of
boys I.E primates has become extremely
rare and those who grow up are relocated
to a dilapidated part of the city where
technology is still primitive here we
get to know that the male population is
looked upon like apes they have little
intelligence they're filthy and they're
always after two things intercourse and
violence ugh disgusting once the
presentation is over Lisa takes the
girls to the edge of the colony from
where they can see the place where men
live after the fall of men the cities
have been turned into slums following
this we are taken to a nearby slum which
is the home of a group of primates with
very limited use of technology and
etiquette their lives are very simple we
can even see some females there probably
some Rebels who couldn't adapt to the
futuristic Society among the men live a
normal looking guy named Guerra who is a
virgin all he wants is to get laid but
at the same time he is very helpful and
considerate of others there is also a
masculine brute named Baron who acts as
the leader of the slum he is sick of the
matriarchal society and wants to
initiate an uprising in one of his
speeches he mentions the 100 Year
history of the slums several decades ago
after women took over the world men were
treated as animals and even used as
livestock but one day Baron's Brave
grandfather escaped their society and
came to the city where he started
building the slums from scratch he even
brought some women with him to reproduce
as everyone listens to the speech with
great interest Lisa arrives there with
her students it turns out that she has
brought them on a field trip to see the
primates or in other terms to see his
Zoo as expected the men are enraged to
see themselves being looked at like
animals After while when Lisa and a
student named Maria reach a restricted
area Guerra approaches them and tries to
hide them In the Heat of the Moment he
also suddenly kisses Lisa taken aback
she quickly blows a whistle and
disorients Guerra but also ends up
attracting the attention of some other
men who arrive at the scene and
apprehend the girls shortly after Baron
organizes a slapping competition the one
who wins can procreate with the women
concerned about their well-being Guerra
decides to participate but to his dismay
he is pitted against a giant fortunately
when the giant swings his hand violently
Guerra Ducks down causing the nearby
Baron to get knocked out taking this is
the perfect opportunity the women flee
to their shuttle while Guerra rushes to
his grandfather's house in the next
scene a shuttle bus stops at a regular
checkpoint to get some batteries after
it starts moving again surprisingly
Guerra comes out from one of the battery
barrels this startles the shuttle owner
Julius who is also a male it turns out
that Julius is a seed keeper whose only
task is to release semen and impregnate
and impregnate women seed keepers are
the only males who are given the
Privileges and respect like their female
counterparts surprisingly Julius who has
never had a friend outside of work finds
Guerra interesting and lets him stay the
two chap for a while and Julius even
drinks the primate's special booze
called moonshine unfortunately for him
he gets so drunk that he ends up jumping
out of the moving shuttle bus now with
Baron's man hot on his tail Gara thinks
of a plan he puts on julius's spare
costume and pretends to be the new seed
keeper a while later the shuttle reaches
a colony named two hills and an
invisible barrier opens up to let the
seed keep her in nervously Guerra gets
down and a beautiful woman on a bicycle
gives him a tour of the city along the
way several women greet him with
excitement give us your seed Lisa is
also amongst the crowd but she doesn't
notice Guerra at night Guerra takes an
oath by biting the holy Apple in front
of live TV promising to reproduce
healthy and smart babies then he is
taken to his chamber to rest but being a
virgin Gara asserts that he wants to
start working right away hence a worker
escorts him in inside the reproduction
chamber where a middle-aged obese woman
named Berta welcomes Guerra much to his
dismay after this he is told to be
seated and a pipe is connected to his
manhood which starts milking it
profusely oh my God at first Guerra
hesitates to go through with the process
but soon he starts having visions of
Lisa and finally calms down surprisingly
on the other hand Lisa has also not been
able to shake Gera from her mind and
keeps thinking about him all the time
the next morning Guerra is introduced to
the reproduction base where seed Keepers
like him are taken care of by beautiful
women the whole day the boys are
pampered fed with delicious dishes and
massaged to keep them fit and happy
overwhelmed with all the girls around
him Gara gets aroused and heads to the
bathroom to perform a hand relief
however when he does so an alarm goes
off in the base it turns out that hand
relief is prohibited in the two hills
colony to make matters worse thinking
about intercourse is also illegal and
the one who has such feelings is called
a homo sapiens sexual holy [ __ ]
elsewhere Lisa and her family which
consists of her mother Paulina and
grandmother Anya are at the local Court
it turns out that the student from
earlier Maria told the authorities that
she was briefly apprehended by the
primates hence she along with Lisa are
tried at the court to check if they are
guilty nervous Lisa opens up to her best
friend Tanya that she was kissed by a
primate but the latter tells her to be
confident as no one is going to know
about it soon the trial begins and
Maria's mom Vivian who happens to be a
high-ranking councilwoman in the colony
tries to put all the blame on Lisa
however Lisa doesn't stay quiet and
reveals that they went to the slums at
Maria's request she even goes on to show
video footage from her AI which verifies
her claims with this Lisa is about to
prove her innocence but just then her
evil best friend Tanya rats her out and
tells everyone that she was kissed by a
primate hearing this everyone is shocked
and the judge punishes Lisa with 80
hours of community service while Tanya
is rewarded 20 social points for her
honesty elsewhere Julius somehow
stumbles upon the slums where he is
approached by grandfather the old man
decides to help him out but only if he
keeps his identity a secret having no
choice Julius agrees later he is taken
to Baron who is hanging out at the local
bar Julius tries to start on a positive
note but Baron makes a mockery out of
him by twisting his finger the same day
Julius has given a haircut to make him
look more presentable soon a lady who is
clearly infatuated by his good looks
approaches him to treat his finger
unfortunately Baron notices this and
becomes envious he then orders one of
his bodyguards the giant to confront the
outsider and take care of him without
any hesitation the Giant obliges and he
challenges Julius to a slap fight later
the preparations for the fighter made
and the entire Community has gathered to
witness the event soon the fight begins
and the giant goes first he slaps Julius
with all his might and takes him down
but to everyone's surprise the latter
gets right back up he then unleashes a
lethal right hand which knocks the giant
out cold never underestimate the power
of a man who withholds his seed on the
other hand Alberta takes all the seed
Keepers out for a walk during the
journey Gara gets tired of all the rules
that they have to strictly follow for
instance if a seed keeper wants to fart
he has to ask permission and enter a
fart capsule to do the deed after a
while the group arrives at a statue
which appears to be of Greta thundberg
turns out that she is regarded as a
goddess in this land while everyone is
busy praying Gara gathers some of his
colleagues and encourages them to have
some fun three of the guys agree and
together they Venture off to the nearby
sea to catch fish there the guys noticed
that Guerra has unshaved legs something
which is prohibited inside two Hills
they also find out that he has a lighter
which is regarded as a dangerous weapon
however instead of being suspicious the
guys alike guerra's rebellious nature
and consider him a role model with this
the group catches some fish and enjoys
the evening until a nearby fire alarm
starts blaring and blows their cover
hence they are sentenced to a full day's
tour of the education center the next
morning asgara is having one of his
regular massages his caretaker is
suddenly replaced and the new one is
revealed to be none other than Lisa it
turns out that she was sent to serve in
the reproduction base as a punishment
both Guerra and Lisa are shocked to see
each other but nonetheless they don't
say anything later the four seed Keepers
who previously violated the community's
protocols are brought to the education
center there they are brainwashed with
several presentations which certify that
men are the superior race and that men
should be dominated the presentations
also endorse other illegal cliches of
the society like having intercourse or
even thinking about it during the tour
Lisa and her grandmother Anya are also
present there both of them watch Guerra
from a distance and laugh at his
clumsiness however Anya who is a bit
old-fashioned and despises the latest
rules finds him kinda cute she also
tells her granddaughter to keep his
identity a secret in the evening after
the group reaches home Guerra gathers
his fellow seed Keepers and makes them
understand that contrary to what they
learned today having erotic desire is
completely normal this Riles up one of
the guys so much that he confronts Lisa
and asks her to undress oh pump the
brakes but but before things get out of
hand Gara intervenes and sends the guy
away hence saving Lisa for the second
time but instead of thanking him Lisa
gives him 30 minutes to run away or else
she will blow his cover to the
authorities nice guys finish last again
meanwhile at the slums Julius has
started gaining a bit of a fan following
enraged that an outsider is trying to
usurp his power Baron orders some of his
men including his right-hand man rat to
finish Julius off following the plan the
group along with Julius heads to an
abandoned department store on the
pretext of Scavenging some supplies
surprisingly Julius is very good at the
work and he manages to extract some
valuable food items the group is further
impressed when Julius manages to
single-handedly thwart an enemy group
named the squirrels who believe that
alcohol is the root of all evil as a
result of all of this they decide to
spare his life and take him back to the
slums on the other hand it is revealed
that the councilwoman Vivian is no saint
after all she is seen having an intimate
moment with the leader of the slums
Baron the following morning Vivian
Compares pictures of the new batch of
seed Keepers and eventually finds out
that the real Julius is missing from
Baron's information during their
encounter last night she also learns
that the Imposter is a primate that is
escaped from the slums wasting no time
she orders her assistant to sound off an
emergency warning throughout the colony
meanwhile a scared Gareth tries to flee
the place but he is stopped by the
invisible barrier with no choice he
covertly sneaks back inside the colony
as the emergency alarms go off he
notices Elisa and pleads with her for
help as expected Lisa wants nothing to
do with him but when Guerra reminds her
of all the times he has come to her
rescue she agrees soon cops starts
swarming the place so Lisa flees with
Guerra unfortunately while they are
running away her ex-best friend Tanya
catches them in the ACT back at the
salons while Baron arrives at the bar to
have a drink he is taken aback to see
Julius alive he angrily asks his men
about why they didn't execute him to
which his right-hand man rat replies
that Julius is a kind man who saved
their lives as the heated confrontation
goes on Julia steps forward demands a
democracy he states that all the
residents of the place deserve equal
opportunity and that their voices should
matter all the people inside the bar
also start chanting for him and hence
left with no options Baron decides to
conduct a friendly meeting the two later
meet in Baron's personal quarters to
talk about their opinions Julius wants
all the people to have a free will while
Baron wants to oppress them forever but
at last the two eventually settle for an
election the winner of which will be the
leader of the slums after Julius leaves
a worried Baron calls rat to his room
and orders him to enter the election as
well he believes that if three men
compete the votes will be divided and
Julius will have a lesser chance of
winning at night the voting ceremony is
commenced and all the residents of the
slums cast their votes one by one when
the results are declared Baron receives
only a single vote but to everyone's
surprise rat wins the election with 18
votes compared to julius's 16. it turns
out that most of the people still don't
trust the latter considering the fact
that he is an outsider elsewhere with
nowhere to go Lisa brings Guerra to her
home where her grandmother Anya tries to
think of ways to make him Escape
unfortunately before she can come up
with a plan Vivian's assistant arrives
at the door to inspect before letting
her in Anya quickly locks Guerra Lisa
and also a pet cat inside the closet
here it is revealed that keeping animals
in captivity or even having them as pets
is also illegal in two Hells soon
Vivian's assistant enters the house and
starts searching for The Hideaway
criminals she reveals that Tanya saw the
primate AKA Guerra running away with
Lisa she then presses on you to give up
the criminals but the latter holds firm
and lies that she hasn't seen them
shortly after the assistant is about to
leave but just then the cat sneezes
inside the closet hence blowing their
cover but before she can inform Vivian
about it Anya smacks her in the head and
knocks her out now with time running out
Anya brings out a motorcycle and tells
Garrett to take it as only a projectile
traveling over the speed of 80
kilometers an hour can penetrate the
invisible barrier she also orders Lisa
to run away from him as she too has
become a wanted criminal in the colony
obeying her order the two set off on
their journey and Guerra accelerates the
motorcycle to exceed the 80 kilometers
per hour mark fortunately the plan works
and the two are able to penetrate the
invisible barrier the impact
disintegrates the motorcycle and tears
their clothes apart but the good thing
is that they have brought some extra
clothes with them now with nowhere to go
Lisa is forced to follow Guerra at night
the two light a fire and sleep together
the next morning Gara catches a squirrel
and Cooks at his breakfast but sadly
Lisa who has lived all her life by
eating vegetables and shrubs is
terrified by the sight of a cooked
animal the episode ends as Lisa screams
out aloud attracting the attention of
some nearby men to see what happens next
watch the second part in series recapped